So let's now go from the culture war question
to one about rights and responsibilities.
We talked about the Trump administration turning
Corona virus into a culture war because they
have to they're losing on the science.
So they're making it a culture war.
Now, I want to focus in on the so-called liberty.
Corona virus protesters.
The people talking about liberty and government
tyranny as the reasons why states must open
and masks must not be worn and I need my hair
dyed and all of this stuff.
They are the ones talking about why churches
and restaurants and hair salons must all be
open right now.
I have to tell you, I'm sympathetic to their
desires.
I'm sick.
I want everything open as soon as possible.
I believe we are only needing to be this closed
because of early failures by not just the
Trump administration, but also many governors.
I am skeptical of a total indefinite shutdown
as an even remotely reasonable thing that
could or should extend more than a minimum
amount of time.
It's bad for people's mental health, it's
terrible for the economy.
But the thing is, I'm regularly proving my
level of responsibility that would go with
the freedoms that I want.
And the problem is that these protesters and
these so-called tyranny people regularly prove
they can't be responsible with the freedom
they claim an absolute right to.
I don't know if this idea originally came
from ELEANOR Roosevelt, but she once wrote,
quote, Freedom makes a huge requirement of
every human being.
With freedom comes responsibility for the
person who is unwilling to grow up.
The person who does not want to carry his
own weight.
This is a frightening prospect.
Restrictions on freedom essentially stem from
people abusing freedoms and forcing a restriction
on those so-called freedom.
So let's let's really dig into it and understand
it.
First of all, I want to be clear.
When the gun people for the last 10 years
that I've been doing the show talk to me about
government tyranny, I never imagined they
were talking about wearing a mask and staying
home to watch Netflix.
Right.
That that we never imagined.
That's actually what they were talking about.
But let's take them at their word that this
is tyranny as they see it.
And it's about the economy and it's about
liberty.
If everyone were responsible, we wouldn't
need nearly as many restrictions when you
were talking about a virus.
A few people can ruin it for everybody.
There's one recent study which estimated 80
percent of the spread is caused by 9 percent
of the people that are infected.
In other words, most people who have the virus
are infecting anyone.
They are infecting zero people.
A small number of people are infecting a whole
bunch of others.
Now, some of these are, of course, not irresponsible
behavior.
People that are causing the spread, but many
of them are.
And so the very people demanding absolute
and total freedom have in many cases show
no evidence that they can actually bear the
responsibility that comes with that freedom.
The same people demanding everything reopen
are often the people continuing to have mass
gatherings, hosting huge services at their
megachurch, refusing to wear a mask as some
kind of political statement.
The reason governors had to put in place restrictions
and then stricter restrictions and then stricter
restrictions is because simply communicating
the facts about the disease didn't get people
to act responsibly.
So over time, people work from home masks
becoming a requirement.
Businesses have to close.
Supermarkets have to put in place more and
more guidelines.
Parks have to close.
They only insist on their rights in a total
vacuum where their responsibilities are not
being met and aren't even being discussed.
It is petulant, childish nonsense to simply
say my rights, my rights, my rights and pretend
that you have no responsibility to society.
And in fact, it's what Donald Trump does.
It's mimicking Trump.
It's basically this.
I want to.
I want to stuff and nothing else matters.
Your right to get your hair dyed so that your
roots don't show must happen in the context
of ensuring that you're not getting people
sick where there's a when and where there
is a deadly virus spreading.
And so then they will shift their bogus bad
faith arguments.
Liberals want the economy closed.
They want to hurt businesses, maybe to hurt
Donald Trump in November.
Find me an actual example with evidence of
someone who makes it clear they want the economy
hurt either for the sake of hurting the economy
or to hurt Donald Trump or whatever.
I will be right there with you in slamming
them.
I've been clear from day one.
Trump has long outstate, is welcome, overstayed
as welcome in the White House.
We didn't need his coronavirus failings.
We don't need a higher death toll to justify
removing Donald Trump in November.
I don't want anybody to lose their business
or their job or their life because of Corona
virus for a political statement.
But the irresponsible people who talk only
about their rights as the reason why we are
here today.
Every right comes with another side of the
coin.
The First Amendment, the right to free speech
and freedom of religion and right to assemble
until.
You're assembling in a way that infringes
on others or using the speech to incite violence.
Use the right responsibly.
The Second Amendment, you have the right to
keep and bear arms, of course.
As long as you behave responsibly in your
life, as long as you don't commit certain
crimes where you have to forfeit your right
to bear those arms, the right comes with responsibility.
The freedom of my fist, as the example goes
to fly around, stops at your nose.
And if I don't use that freedom responsibly,
I will be in trouble.
So every time one of these protesters is demanding
their rights in a vacuum with no discussion
of the responsibility that they will bring.
Let's hear from them.
What responsible behavior?
They are bringing to the table.
Otherwise, it's just B.S. and that's what
we're increasingly seeing.
Make sure you follow me on Twitter at David
Pakman.
And remember, this show has a daily hour-long
podcast.
If you watch on YouTube, for example, you
can get the full hour long audio podcast where
on Stitcher where on i-Tunes?
We're on Spotify.
All of those things.
Subscribe free to the Daily Audio podcast.
We'll take a break and be back after this.